hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The
Crooked Man okay I'm not gonna get on a
monologue this time I'm just gonna get
right into the game I recording this
sequentially so I don't know what that
other choice did um if it did anything
game-breaking that you think I need to
go back and check then please let me
know all right deep fissure in the wall
behind the eastern bookshelves in the
basement storehouse repairs needed okay
so there's a hole in the wall that I'm
gonna go find out what's going on
alright so I am in a school of some sort
I why I have no idea okay criminal law
civil law international law and
criminology all different people part of
the staff you give Maguire Stasi Lizzy
um lefty Lewis and none of those names
seemed like they were interesting so I
don't know if they were important at all
completely dark outside okay nothing
going on there
what are these rooms anyway okay the
infirmary is locked I'm guessing that
you know III don't even know why we're
going in these different locales but
it's quite interesting I mean there's
been a lot of oh no don't start that
would make it back here you [ __ ] I'm
coming for you was there someone there I
couldn't really see them in the dark
well I'm coming for you baby baby I'm
coming for you
is that a safe box of tools ooh the box
would be too heavy to take up ER could
probably take two tools from it um let's
try the hammer and a screwdriver
probably something you'll need I'll come
back if I need anything else why can't
all I carry - that's stupid that's
stupid or whatever why are there so many
abandoned places in this entire town no
idea oh well I'm not one to complain
about game logic I know better than to
question my superiors you know I
actually do want to try to make one of
these RPG horror Maker games I mean it'd
probably be fairly easy to learn and I
already have a good story that I've
cooked up from it I've told a few people
about it but hopefully I can get
something that can be sincerely creepy
and I have just like a really dark dark
idea for the story that I want to make
I'm not going to spoil it at all so even
if you ask me about I'm not going to
tell you about it because
it's going to be something that needs to
be played so if I ever get a chance some
free time in myself because I have not
had any free time to do anything at all
because I've literally been booked up
for days and days and days from time I
get up to the time I go to bed and I
love that I love that I love making
videos for you guys like that is
something that is close to my heart and
and something that I really truly enjoy
but I just M there aren't enough hours
in the day to do everything that I want
to do but you know it's a good problem
to have it's not a bad problem I am
totally appreciative for the chance and
like I said in the last one I did drone
too long about sincerely guys thank you
for all that but galliano I've been
drawn it about that let's get back into
the game okay I haven't been able to see
anything that's going to help me
Mitchell's Michele's dissertation made
it into a scientific magazine Oh
Michaels I'm so happy for him I knew
when he joined my class he be a prodigy
I also realized he and I have the same
birthday
I used my birthday as a security code so
I feel like maybe I should change it
when's your birthday who are you Michael
so Michael and this person are in the
same class so I can if I can find who
was in Michael's whose class Michael was
in maybe I don't know it's kind of
confusing I'm gonna be going back and
forth a lot I bet oh boy
oh hello glowy thing documents are
strewn on the desk a key to the room is
among them key to John Keith's room my
apologizes or hey QB I have the hiccups
Oh doh
okay security box requires a passcode
hey why are these shades drawn okay I
can't do anything and there's something
on the get over there some sort of a
notebook times are changing our existing
laws are no use anymore we must surprise
the father of our law to find the true
answer was that it was that it what kind
of crazy-ass rambling is that well
whatever okay so I got some key to
somewhere John Keith's room Sammy
Peterson was open was this okay that's
locked with a six digit PIN so I got to
find John Keith's room
kind of school is this is weird rate
Wayne rate Wayne what a stupid name
indeed law to needs a numeric
representation after all basic things
such as on or off zero or one can
represent much more complex numbers
using the smallest elements blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah well that was
boring I'm glad I read that oh why does
this Scott law school have a math books
I'm terrible in math oh oh we got a
puzzle here oh my goodness oh my oh boy
okay so that's probably gonna be need to
be referenced later oh come on
okay so there's a bunch of bit Coons new
power trashcan is empty well isn't this
just lovely there's a lot of chests with
pass codes maybe uh something about
buying a bookshelf man so many security
boxes why lots of books nothing
important man was junk earlier I lost a
note with my security box password thus
I couldn't get into the computer room
and the headmaster got angry at me this
is the worst thought I had it when I was
writing for a seminar in the Reference
Room maybe I left it in a book somehow I
should go look in the Reference Room if
I use my ID as a password like Andrew
does that I wouldn't forget but that's
risky but if you if you just use
whatever then you have my problem okay
this is gonna this gonna get really
complicated because I need to remember
that Andrews password is the same as his
ID what the hell this is way too much to
remember can I get a journal or notebook
too got all of this down okay I think
I've explored everything so I still need
to find what was his name John Keith I
need to find John Keith excuse me yeah
looking for John Keith lefty-loosey
sound like really crappy gang member
names
hey lefty Lewis over there give me over
to John Keith a reference room damn it
of course it's locked well why not
computer room parlor where is John Keith
excuse me have you seen John Keith
anywhere
back I'm gonna in the basement oh hello
see stubborn won't open base bookshelves
locked storeroom okay nothing down there
there's only one other place to go damn
it
Oh John Keith must be down here better
be down here else I'm gonna janitor's
room infirmary phi john cleese he's
probably like right over here oh my god
faculty room oh how about better really
Stacy Lizzie there's a key uh the
infirmary key I still haven't found John
Keefe where's John Keith oh my god oh my
god John Keith lecture halls lecture
halls okay is that John keys is for the
lecture halls alright then
is that good and important that I need
to know uh whatever let's just go to the
infirmary because that's the only thing
that I have here I'm so confused and
lost as it'll pass though okay oh this
is rather plain I was expecting a
nightmare of blood and guts in here
found a parlor key in one of the drawers
oh man this is just gonna be a non-stop
key hunt I'm gonna be going over one
place to find a key to the other
actually that reminds me because this
game was made by the same guy that made
paranoia AK and that had kind of a
similar mechanic we had you get one key
and then you go to another area to
unlock it in the house so I mean it's
not bad but I mean come on I mean man I
don't even remember where the parlor was
I believe it was on this floor
maybe Reference Room no computer room
parlor here we go okay unlock the parlor
all right what's in here big old clock
on the wall lined with anthologies and
ooh what
LOL guess it's wire art of some sort not
sure what's supposed to be though
apparently it was made by rate wayne one
of the lectures huh interesting clock
has stopped completely dark out what
does this mean
maybe i could if i read it from the
other side it'll look no I can't huh
maybe I rate Wayne I didn't get a key in
this room so I don't know what's going
on here damn it oh my god this is gonna
be a nightmare of walking around it's
gonna be scary for all different reasons
oh no you'll be trapped looking for keys
forever and then you die a horrible
death
see if I use John Keith Qian okay can i
no I cannot no markiplier you're a giant
it II don't even try to do that
ahh where's on Keith where's John Key
duh where's John Keith I'm just like
John Keith's monster black Smith Monster
again coming through the halls just
stomping back and forth duh where do I
use this key where's John Keith were
junkie I'm so sorry my neighbor's I
apologize sincerely if they can hear me
scream they can hear me apologize lucky
dog am I'm probably gonna have to
consult the walkthrough again because oh
my god come on you gotta be joking me
you gotta be you gotta be joking me yeah
sandy Peterson tell me your secrets
where's John Keith all the little
kitties from this Elementary River like
why does he want to know where our
teacher is
John Key like the Terminator looking for
John Connor
Yankees oh my god
I don't even know anymore I don't even
know anymore I don't know who I am
rate Wayne wasn't that a thing someone
was saying about rate Wayne was
something solver something oh oh maybe
something was in this no zero one
artistic motion captured about
mathematics oh my god my brain my brain
duh the markiplier monster didn't need
what okay now she's a rare I won't be
scared by a door where's John Key this
is lovers your bathroom I've looked in
every room come on I looked at all of
them look Maguire MacLaine love reet
waned friends more you know I think you
guys have noticed a train trend about my
gameplay playthroughs is just that when
I get lost I get so much weirder like
just bring you the weird line clean
there you go read my word what if I'd
evolved into is this really what I do
long-wear junkie ah no time for that I'm
sleepwalking a bit I don't know what to
do I don't know what to know I don't
know what to do and obviously you guys
know that I don't Kenny I'm I'm done I'm
done I'm done I can't I can't get this
I'll figure it out at some point I'll
look up a walkthrough or something like
that
I don't know but
I'm not just gonna sit here go were the
black man or sorry we're junkie
over and over cuz that can get old all
right I'll just gotta do it from that
fifteen minutes those who want the game
played and it's over but I'm just gonna
stand here into the camera
war junkie Oh Marc Mars so funny
uh-huh okay anyway I'm done so thank you
all so much for watching the worst
episode I've ever made in my entire life
hope you had a great fun time have a
nice day with the rest of your life so
thank you all so much for watching
blah blah annotation to give us an ass I
haven't put up annotations there for
weeks what am i doing so anyway thanks
again see you in the next one bye bye